breaking news now UCI cycling's
governing body ban Armstrong for life
and Mary and Jonesy would stow steroids
in the refrigerator I have no one to
blame but myself over the years
scientific progress has made easier and
faster to detect athletes who don't but
it's also helped make it easier to dope
fewer court so what's the real story
behind doping in sport just explain to
me warm anti-doping agencies are up
against yeah they have an impossible
task essentially which is looking for a
huge list of substances and then looking
for the the classic ways I'm doping are
using anabolic steroids that's that's
really what they started with but it's
not the most refined way of doping so
then on top of that you have human birth
these are still being used today a lot
more self sophisticated now blood doping
they were talking about it so EPO which
is a drug that thickens your blood
I'm so inconsistent the number of red
blood cells in your system and oxygenate
your muscles every day essentially
there's a new set of plugs that are
being designed
combinations and cocktails I've been
designed science has always played
catch-up to the ways athletes and
coaches avoid detection of drugs in
sport for most of the history of
anti-doping the focus was on trying to
identify particular chemicals in urine
we went to talk to James Tosa who writes
about sport here at the economist to
find out how the science has moved on 10
years ago and the aim there is not to
find specific substances but rather
unusual changes for as long as the
Olympics have existed athletes have
cheated but it's only since the
International Olympic Committee started
testing for doping in 1968 that the
cheaters have been officially caught the
game changed in 2004 with the
introduction of a bio bank allowing the
storage and retesting of athlete samples
over an eight-year period then in 2009
Kim biological passports since then more
than athletes have been opened but
that's not the full picture in an
anonymous survey at the 2011 World
Athletics Championships an astonishing
44 percent of athletes admitted to
doping within the last year but
typically only one to two percent of
samples test positive and most doping
has in fact been detected years after it
happened and had it not been for the
admissions of two Russian whistleblowers
and other intelligence many of those
cases could still be unknown
[Music]
[Applause]
a leader watt is a British Parliament
and former world champion as an
outspoken critic of doping in sports we
wanted to hear Alys take on how big the
gap between doping and it's so why have
biological passports not lived up to
their promise as the way to stamp out
doping and what's the alternative
there's a scientists in the South of
England who seems to have an answer so
we headed to Brighton to meet him the
athlete's biological passport system
it's a very clever concept it's weakness
at the moment is its that it's based on
a handful of biomarkers compounds within
the body that reflect the fact that
there's been a change in one's red blood
cells for example but it's very very
clear that a large number or evading
detection because the the markers can
also be easily easily manipulated and
one that's going to separate Yanis bitsy
laddus is on the medical and scientific
commission of the IOC the International
Olympic Committee he spent more than a
decade honing a new method to spot blood
doping it's an approach that might
eventually be used to test and help
stamp out doping of any kind will they
have stored it as whole blood yeah but
how much do they have do you know so
what we are pioneering here in this
laboratory is trying to utilize newer
technologies like these gene chip
technologies where we can where we can
look at every single gene that switched
on and off in the human body to see
whether we can use this approach to the
detection of drugs in sport
[Music]
Yanis plants add thousands of biomarkers
through genetic sequencing there are
around 21,000 genes in the body several
hundred switch on when an athlete takes
a blood thickening drug or has a blood
transfusion
and this changes the athletes genetic
signature by analyzing these changes
which can be detected weeks possibly
even months later
Yanis can spot blood doping the method
used and even roughly when it took place
but the final stage of Alice's research
could be the most challenging it will be
labor-intensive and time-consuming
require access to a DNA sequencer and a
supercomputer and it will cost an
estimated four million pounds I must
acknowledge that I am one of the most
funded scientists in anti-doping and I'm
extremely frustrated so far Yanis is
secured over half a million pounds from
sponsors and wada the world anti-doping
agency and a Chinese company has agreed
to lend him a sequencer let's
demonstrate even a small way that we can
detect one athlete scientifically I'm
confident this is the way forward
Yanis is struggled to secure funding is
typical of the wider challenge facing
anti-doping researchers it's very clear
to me that wada needs more money and the
question is ways that money gonna come
from what really struck us when we
talked to Yanis wasn't just a science it
was this funding gap organizations that
say that they want to read sport of
doping haven't always put their money
where their mouth is so we've made
another film to find out why and to
untangle the politics around the world's
foremost anti-doping agency we need to
understand that water as an institution
is weak there was resistance from the
Olympic movement where there was a
desire to have more control
is basically a naked legislator it
produces rules that it has absolutely no
power and capacity to enforce to learn
more about wider the IOC and the
structural challenges in stopping doping
watch the rest of our film by clicking
on the link opposite you can click on
the other link if you like to read some
of our resources thank you for watching
and don't forget to subscribe
you